[Music]
every waterway in the united states is
supposed to be safe enough to swim in
every single day
but of course they're not
i'm getting in to these contaminated
waterways
someone's got to risk something
if people see that image they start to
ask themselves why is that guy in there
that starts a discussion that can lead
to a cleanup
[Music]
my name's christopher swain and i've
swum over
3 000 miles in
over 25 different contaminated waterways
in north america i want to advocate for
these waterways and i can energize
cleanups
i learned to swim as a kid i was the kid
who didn't want to get out of the water
as i got older and i think this is true
for many of us i started to become aware
that waters are contaminated with
everything from arsenic to zinc
everything from human waste to nuclear
waste we saw our waterways as dumpsters
we saw them as
sewers legally speaking since 1972 when
the federal clean water act passed all
navigable u.s waterways have to be safe
for swimming and fishing and drinking if
they're a freshwater creek
dozens and dozens of those waterways
were in and around new york city
newtown creek is the worst of those
it is contaminated with lots of things
heavy metals toxic chemicals raw sewage
and one of the largest ongoing oil
spills in the history of the united
states
so in some way
we stole this waterway from ourselves
what i'm saying is let's turn that
around
[Music]
when
i decide to take on a waterway
this is
my puncture resistant dry suit
i take all these measures on all my
swims to protect my body and to protect
my health i wear a cap i wear goggles i
wear earplugs i never put my head under
even so i've gotten sick lots of times
rashes skin infections ear infections
respiratory infections
it's a hazard that goes with the
territory
the reason
nobody has swung the length of newtown
creek in history is that
at least in the last hundred years it's
been far too disgusting no one in their
right mind would go in there
[Music]
it's like swimming through a dirty
diaper
that's been garnished with oil gasoline
and trash
every part of your skin wants to crawl
so why do i push on and do it
i'm doing this out of love like i really
do love the water and i don't have a lot
to work with i'm not a wealthy person
i'm not a scientist what i've got is my
body and my life to offer
i'm going to keep going back in my dry
suit and my hazmat gear until these
waterways are clean and when they're
clean
i'm going to get into these clean
waterways in my bathing suit and enjoy
them with my fellow citizens
[Music]
you